how evil you think he is how did you say
evil or medieval medieval i mean i don't
know i i know no i get that but how evil
you think you you think he's an evil guy
yeah i do and i but i also think there
are uh a lot of people who we look up to
who
anyone from the other side of the the
river would say oh that's an evil you
know bastard too
i think he's evil i i can understand why
people don't but
there's a there's a quote that
when you murder people
yeah well there's a quote that um i saw
on the lex fordman podcast i don't
remember the name but the guy said
listen
some great men
are not necessarily good men
uh and
there's no doubt that he is a cunning
political figure to stay at the top of
russian politics for the better half of
two decades and then some when you could
easily just have a drink of a cocktail
and end up dead
he's got to be
don't
undermine i'm not saying you but don't
undermine how savvy of a political
figure this man is uh yeah and again he
would no make that mistake exactly he
was he he got brexit through and you
know
from his couch so the the um
the the the cancer thing is concerning
though i had no idea about that i think
that's a
a story that we're going to need to keep
our eyes on there's a part of it where
let's just say if you have something
where you know you're going to die you
make decisions in a different way
because urgency is at the top
so there is a part of it where if that
is the case
now what that decision-making process is
going to be nobody knows
but if a guy like that is driven by i'm
gonna get even with you or revenge
i think he's gonna spend the last uh
you know a few years or a few months or
whatever he's got doing some kind of a
retaliation is that gonna be nuclear is
that gonna be cyber i don't know
their ability to do cyber attack is
apparently better than anybody else in
the world so if they wanted to really
make our life a living hell
and confuse the [ __ ] out of everybody
mess with elections mess with this mess
with that they can definitely do that
but we'll see what's going to happen i
don't know if he's going to do nuclear
but
one of us is going to be right the
challenges if they do nuclear we may
never be able to tell the other guy
you're right that's the problem exactly
we may not have that many of his kids
either that's going to that he's going
to be or he won't be he won't be he
won't be able to protect us
during global nuclear warfare i mean
right there's there's no safe island
somewhere where you're not going to get
fall out i have i i don't know so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]